A common answer we've heard from our
students when we asked them about
the word delegate is that it
made him think of a relationship
between a manager and an employee,
or parent and a child.
Perhaps you've also experienced a
situation where work has been passed on
or delegated to you.
In iOS delegation works
much the same way.
But it can be between
any types of objects.
It really just means getting one
object do the work for the other.
In the case of AV audio recorder it
does not know anything about our view
controllers or even your app.
It does know that once it finishes
recording it can inform the other class,
our record view controller
that it's finished.
The delegate,
the record view controller,
could then do the work of whatever needs
to be done with the recorded audio.
In this way you can use AV
audio recorder as a tool
to just record the audio and
it calls out to its delegates.
The record view controller
to do something with it.